ha ha
I'm ready hey how's it going bros -
today we have a very special game in
front of us today is a very special day
we're playing layers of fear this is a
brand new fresh out the box
jeez guys why do I talk like that horror
game
it's about paintings and how creepy they
are that's all I know
look at that loading screen stefan alia
painting fantastic let's play it give me
a cutscene intro I'm ready
the torment I have to endure look at all
these paint hear the scratching in my
head my hands cut so many times on
broken bottles each night drowning in a
cold sweat the right way
way to bring back what life took from me
the only precious thing what is it
every part I'd that is painted with
feeling is a part of the our ooh looks
fancy look at it look at that that's a
great painting I love baby but don't
quote me on that please don't want to go
to jail I don't like I don't think I can
handle it alright this is my house looks
gorgeous
hello house very good house whoa
very very nice
what what was that get me this cannon
stupid Allah what are you doing in here
you think I want some stupid why am I
doing this action stupid that vodka no
is paprika cat dammit
well at least we're we're stocked up on
paprika some God unknown reason drawers
better bet babbitt I bet did that for no
good reason
Kenneth yeah Christ it's what I need to
chill all right
this Lantern I shall take it no but look
at that lens flare though this is pretty
cool so far
I don't know anything in life in general
but I'm guessing we're gonna go up sit
up let us say sad caring friend that me
and that was me note sir I didn't touch
the workshop I can't read what that says
just like you asked although I could
imagine
also if you care so much for that room
maybe you should pay more attention to
where you lead the keys I bought them
back I brought them back to your office
have a nice thing what an [ __ ]
telling me how to live my god dammit
what a dick alright where's my office oh
this is creepy why am I going down here
god this is super scary let's go
upstairs
hello paintings Oh God you look hot as
[ __ ] man it look like is stuck a potato
up his face like a really big baked
potato am i right ladies
up top yeah
Oh God what that [ __ ] is wrong with this
place
it's very very nice I must be rich my
favorite song my favorite song and oh
wow worse Jesus Christ okay where were
we
hello another another note how in the
heaven's name am I supposed to read that
I cannot that is too tiny for my tiny
face all right where's the keys come on
I ain't got time for this [ __ ]
[Music]
then I just pick up I picked up the game
genius genius pin strikes again all
right brick a beautiful office they've
got to say ten out of ten would office
again all right what do we got here a
dog and a little letter dog and woman
morning her Apple probably a melon or
maybe a bowling ball maybe she just
hates bowling what do we got in here
then Oh God
[ __ ] a microphone all right fine fine
I'll go down go down this is a mirror
and my misspoke
potato man you look beautiful as I was
potato man right now we can use our key
to get in here oh my god that's the
painting let's to look at it after we
look at baby butts sorry
man it must be a fake guy a head or
something I love this one it's [ __ ]
man on dead war Boppity Boppity pata
deep roots and boots remember you're yes
great well there's me hey hey how you
doing hey look at me yay yeah like I got
my face yes that's the face beautiful
details look like I did some painting on
my own is it whispering to me paintings
can't talk I know this because my mother
told me and my mother was a wise man she
knew a lot of okay this whispering needs
to end now am i crying I will bring you
drag if I have to I will make it right
honey I promise
[Music]
- [ __ ] is this so much drama over this
piece of [ __ ] alright I'll paint it give
it give me a penny I'll paint it you me
painting
give me ya me give give me gas
god dammit alright you know what then I
don't know what to do that's right it's
got a good base going it's a nice
landscape with some babble about that
depth at the beautiful sky are you
trying to tear why are you crying no
you're dancing look at you you're a
dancing man you're a dancing [ __ ] did it
did it did it did it did it did it did
it did it did it no am I the only one
fan of that song that's okay
that's great I love that song like it
was my child I don't think you can have
a child song if I had one it would be
that one all right well I best be going
then good times good times were had wait
am his second minute second this is not
where we came from hello hello I suspect
the jump-scare I can smell them from a
mile away you know oh oh it's the dirty
one oh oh oh it's gonna [ __ ] me up real
good
oh it's been rotten where that see like
them oh there we go alright
keep trying the doors that's how you do
it that's what my momma told me that is
the painting of yes I like the paintings
I like creepy pings myself sir myself so
this is all this good news good news
ah of course ah Jeff Larina what did I
say what did I say Jesus Christ all
right you got me there one points to the
game zero defense that's fine all right
I'll get you next time
you know what I'll be going on my way
now thank you very very very kinda thank
you very much kindly very much
thank you very much candidate kind of
been going in socco's game you don't
know much maybe I am so far what are you
gonna do about it self a [ __ ] let's try
you yeah I call this sofa [ __ ] you
can't tell me what you do I'll go and
I'll go in the closet or Tom Cruise that
[ __ ] what do we got
alright I'll go back god damn it hello
don't judge me so [ __ ] you don't know
[ __ ]
there we go fantastic people are
whispering there's some and there's the
one man thing that's that dead baby but
again ah there we go
oh no but this this opossum yes
for eight five remember that piss good
thing I have photographic memory
I'll never forget anything now what that
[ __ ] wasn't yes of course as I was
saying just kidding that was a joke god
damn it
the whispers hello the past holds back
to the thought alone the most beautiful
piece of art doesn't have my name on it
is killing me so will you marry me oh
that's that's lame that was a lame
pickup line man come on man you got you
can do better than that [ __ ] no wonder
she liked me man what the [ __ ] so you
better get seven it's not an iPad I
think they existed at this century thing
okay all right
and see ya how's everyone doing here
it's very interest didn't think so very
interesting concept god [ __ ] damn it
don't you tangle Oh a bangle okay here
yes so many great things ah no man I'm
great at this game
[ __ ] you all right well I bet I bet now
it's gonna work this is weird locking
mechanism in this game Oh dominoes I I
love Tom yes what the actual [ __ ] this
one is great job not if it doesn't up
violet oh my god Am I I can't see
anything did I fall down the chimney oh
god you bear you [ __ ] you did this
thank you okay close it step
but it's it's creepy that I am what
funds [ __ ] Jesus Christ you did it Joe
everyone need a chump chill the [ __ ] out
I'm gonna pull this lever now yes
that's gonna solve everything yeah I did
it I did it
[ __ ] yo chairs and sofas and paintings
oh my god [ __ ] me what stop no no no no
no no no no no no I refuse but what did
I say now this is not Titanic [ __ ] out
hold that pose I want to get all those
lovely curves just right oh my god this
guy's me hello hello how's it going
where's that later
all right I write Matthew McConaughey
I'm ready to write at a [ __ ] you up bro
got it real nice I write I write books
love books
yes what's that I hear someone manned it
for the fun stop I told you to stop III
I asked you nicely Jesus
it's for the books I said I love books
and the game was like hey we won two
more books and now I'm like [ __ ] you and
now I feel bad all right what do I did
do I get out of here
I think I should get out of here that's
a great great painting my favorite ten
out of ten would
Yeah right
how are you people whispering people are
definitely whispering hello don't you
talk to me I'm all right okay
you okay together you cry oh that must
be naked lady taking lady Nichkhun naked
lady thick naked ah don't worry I would
save you fab another bat bat bat that
bad shame on your potato man shame on
your potato man I trusted you like you
were my tack damn it how do I say potato
lady so hard to save potato lady sees
there's that but child again I don't
understand what's something potato lady
no no no no Nick Italy this is so creepy
it's very atmospheric to see ah the
kitchen we're back in the kitchen man I
am really getting I bet I just like took
some weird drugs and I'm just tripping
the [ __ ] out in my own house I bet nice
surprise yup
what no no no I saw that no no I see
your tree no apples don't come from
trees read two paintings [ __ ] you
no oh no naked lady hey ha ha
I'm ready [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] all of
you stop just stop now you speak rude
nice rude
you're an [ __ ] I had to find a knife
not one of those bread ones it needed to
be as sharp as a razor so I used a razor
in fact and then carefully flayed the
skin booze helped keep my hand steady we
found a piece of skin
I think it's Harry Potter's forehead to
be completely honest with you come on
don't tell me tell me I'm not lying all
right all right without it that was cool
oh yes we will go back to naked lady no
what do you want you don't know me
you're just a painting no no no you
can't talk to me like that
as we gonna add the first
you did it the painting is coming
together in really clever way of
storytelling that is some disgusting
piece of [ __ ]
are those camels flamingos sweet Jesus
did you diss buy half of the department
store honey you don't even know yet if
it's gonna be a boy or a girl
those are some cute shoes that margin I
would love those okay we did it we've
done our business we done diddly diddly
diddly DepEd about it all right well I
best be going on Murray thank Haleh now
this trick again
yes yes yes yes no and now now this door
will be open old trick new dog old dog
new table these elevators alright
yes denim have fun oh that's no that's
fine no no no it's fine it's my nail god
all right price we're gonna have to end
that episode there this game is amazing
I'm so impressed by it I think it's
really cool I think this could be
potentially a really good series
if you bros show your support so if you
want more of this leave a comment like
it share it do whatever you want and I
really appreciate it so I'll see you in
the next one as soon as I can all right
stay awesome boom funny six down see em
defeat them